[Musica]
un piccolo privilegio per me ho chiesto
di meglio guardare non perdere i fogli
questi appunti che ho messo insieme in
fila un po di deco alla sapendo e ne
sono consapevole oggi di avviarmi in una
selva oscura perché il tema che ho
scelto e anche molto intimo molto
personale e chimico perfino io non credo
in questa mia lunga attività che di
comunicazione in italia nel mondo reale
l'ho mai affrontato così felicemente
anche ma così familiar mente come faccio
oggi qui con noi con voi un tema quindi
che ci porta in uno dei secondo me del
dl dei concetti delle analisi il mistero
dell'intuizione oltre la scienza sì
perché si chissà quanti testi ci saranno
scientifici sull'intuizione ma non credo
però che questo argomento questa materia
sia stata mai analizzata bene e meglio
soprattutto nel mondo di chi è chiamato
a reagire alle idee ai pensieri alle
azioni quindi ci tenevo a dire oltre la
scienza perché quello che adesso di rho
ragionando con voi e che è quello che io
credo sia parte fondamentale di una
persona una donna un uomo di un'azienda
che nel suo cammino deve dare risposte a
se stesso e agli altri ci si trova
sempre un eterno conflitto tra la testa
il corpo
chi comanda a volte la testa fa tante
cose a volte confuse e le vuole subito
mettere in pratica quindi braccia e
altro devono eseguire un po questi
ordini
volte si sveglia la mattina dove il
corpo credo di essere il pensiero ma è
sbagliato quindi bisogna mettere sempre
un po di ordine nella nostra vita
prima di entrare vorrei dire che chissà
quanti di voi di noi abbiamo adottato
certe figure certe immagini certi
disegni delle poesie dei testi adottati
perché in quel momento abbiamo avuto
qualcosa una reazione di fronte a chi
per esempio gli aironi mousse morse che
da quando era bambino mi ha inquietato e
non faccio altro dove stanno nei musei
di mettermi lì e parlare con niero
nimbus boats capire queste sue
intuizioni l'altro che tutti quanti
conosciamo e amiamo e ac bordo perché
questi due sono un elemento importante
di questo mio percorso cosa comunicano
quali modelli
io li adottate e che comunicano terrore
genio spesso del male follia ma c'è una
geometria della follia e prove da questi
elementi adottati
io cerco di capire cosa mi trasmettono
quale è come un quadro di tanti secoli
fa possa fatto interrogare ma che cos'è
l'intuizione qual è il tempo
dell'intuizione il luogo uno spazio non
certo per me non esiste esiste sempre un
tempo un momento è un luogo per
l'intuizione è l'impressione secondo me
e rompe nella nostra vita
esattamente come quando una zanzara ci
punge non ce ne accorgiamo perché ci
narcotizza e subito dopo però noi
abbiamo la reazione
a quella intuizione e qui scatta
un'altra epoca
bellissima e quella della estasi nella
solitudine quando tu sia acceso qualcosa
devi innamorarti subito devi far la tua
questa intuizione però devi stare da
solo devi stare da solo perché la devi
digerita la devi vivere appunto credevi
impossessare e proprio in questa epoca
scatta un'altra cosa che il disagio il
disagio si è parlato prima
sappiamo che ad altri saggio nascono
nelle opportunità ma questa è proprio
l'epoca il tempo dove dal disagio
scaturiscono tanti opportunità tanti
suggerimenti che ci dà appunto
l'intuizione un altro aspetto che per me
parliamo del 1971 meno 171 vedi un film
pier paolo pasolini il decameron
se qualcuno di voi lo va a rivedere per
favore
forse li capite che cos'è anche
l'intuizione vissuta proprio pasolini
faceva il pittore in questo film è un
certo momento lui non riusciva a trovare
la creatività per dipingere la chiesa e
mentre stava doveva andare chi ha preso
nata la campanella i monaci a mangiare
quindi le refettorio scende ma si siede
come un matto come una folle
all'improvviso si estranea e tra fiat
corre via tutti i monaci lo guardano
questa scena mi ha molto sempre colpito
che mi fa capire che quello era il
momento di un qualcosa che si aspettava
quindi gioco col tempo ma in quel luogo
è avvenuto il luogo e scappò via e fece
un'opera memorabile
un'altra cosa è questa pure questo mi ha
sempre colpito la babele va bene
importantissimo la torre di babele e se
non ci fosse la babele quindi la
confusione io credo che si dovrebbe
inventare perché da lì appunto che
l'intuizione si fa materia e ti spinge a
davide a valorizzare che cosa le forme
diverse e linguaggi diversi popoli
diversi le comunicazioni diversa quindi
tu sei chiamato a trovare una soluzione
che non è solo linguistica dottor m li
sappiamo come andrà a finire
o come inizio però è importante la
babele perché d'avino noi riusciamo a
trovare ulteriori soluzioni questi
disegni questo percorso solo un percorso
che mi hanno amy segnano fortissimamente
nella mia vita con l'adozione di certe
storie che sono personali ma che poi
sviluppandole possono diventare anche un
po collettive e poi però dobbiamo
passare da quello che la parte anche più
diciamo importante dai sogni ai segni a
volte la comunicazione e quindi questo è
un elemento importante sognare segnare
comunicare comunicare significa far
partecipare tanti tutti o quel gruppo
che sta con te che deve condividere con
te un percorso quindi a volte comunicare
diciamo è un altro di quegli aspetti che
sivas ha studiato quindi una volta che
ti sei innamorato dell'idea e tu
la cacciata fuori la resa forma poi deve
diventare materia e quindi pure io ho
adottato per esempio alcune poesie
oggi ve ne segnalo due che conoscete a
memoria però una è chiusa e l'altra è
aperta cioè ci dà l'opportunità ci danno
l'opportunità di avere un elemento
importante vediamo
ecco quasimodo la conosciamo tutti
quanti ed è subito sera ognuno sta solo
sul cuor della terra trafitto da un
raggio di sole ed è subito s'era chiuso
poche parole ci ha detto tutto ma
possiamo continuare però ci dà
l'opportunità di aprire ancora l'anno al
nostro cervello da nostro modello
diciamo di intuizione anche in questa
parola quest'altro invece no questo
invece come se fosse traduciamolo in un
cortometraggio ci dice esattamente lì
che cosa sta succedendo fiammiferi
accesi uno per uno nella notte il primo
per farti vedere tutto il viso
il secondo per vederti gli occhi
l'ultimo per vedere la tua bocca e tutto
il buio per ricordarmi queste cose
mentre visti fra le braccia è chiuso non
ci dà più opportunità di andare oltre e
un quadro esatto di quello che ne stiamo
vedendo appunto un cortometraggio e
quindi ho detto una scena del film
ritroviamo al conflitto al conflitto
neuro cerebrale
io credo e penso che il conflitto che
dovremmo avere tutti noi stessi ci deve
inquietare ma noi siamo chiamati appunto
a governare le inquietudini e a
governare sapendo è consapevole di
essere incoscienti e un'altra di quelle
bellezze della nostra esistenza
l'incoscienza cioè di andare oltre
quanto anche nei due interventi di prima
sono uscite fuori sempre due elementi
importanti tipo perché lo fai ma chi te
lo fa fare non avrai successo non avrei
non andare avanti con i secoli ma non si
va da nessuna parte
e sapete tutti che uno dei tre parole
che io delle quali mi faccio governare
ed è un operativo è un imperativo anche
per tutti si può fare si deve fare e
perché no quindi è perfetto questo nel
momento in cui noi dobbiamo governare il
presente ma purtroppo per chi vive in un
modo diverso e in un mondo spesso in
conflitto con il cervello con il
pensiero
il presente è già passato e il presente
e al presente si sostituisce il futuro
certe volte l'angoscia si prova a non
vivere come quando dice pure avuto 18
anni quando se uno dicesse che bella
vita a volte noi siamo chiamati a non
vivere quello che vivono gli altri
quelle stagioni belle dove puoi dire
c'ero anch'io ma quando ti capita che in
ogni cosa che venne presente già passato
e cioè quello che stai facendo è già
futuro c'è sempre un regno di mezzo
della tua esistenza della coscienza del
tuo intelletto della tua vita che non
governi e non vi e non vivi più quindi
ritorniamo alla potenza della
comunicazione la comunicazione è così
complesso e così diversa e così posso
dire oggi non ne parliamo prove della
difficoltà di trovare una linea di
comunicazione
però ho sempre preferito comunicazioni
che al di là di quelle social sappiamo
tutti una comunicazione olfattiva visiva
fisica alla fine quando tu comuni che
devo dire qualcosa al nostro sindaco di
salerno per esempio come ti parlo di
porto soltanto un progetto gli dico solo
vorrei fare questo
no lo devo far entrare nel mondo bio e
gli devo fare una comunicazione che in
quel momento per il tempo che ha ma per
l'intuizione che deve scattare nella sua
testa dev'essere proprio olfattiva devi
sentire l'odore di quello che noi
andiamo a promuovere lo desideri dalle
parole debbono diventare immagini e
quindi deve vedere quello che non c'è e
soprattutto odorare quello che ci sarà
quindi mettere energia nella
comunicazione l'energia che in un'altra
cosa estremamente importante quindi
fissare concetti e delinearle le forme
facciamo un gioco
io mi sono divertito tanto per esempio
lo faccio sempre sono dei momenti dove
tu capisci alcune cose una banalità non
lo deve fare chi guida ti sta vicino al
guidatore ma provate che quando
camminate in macchina l'ho detto qualche
volta questo provate a vedere da lontano
un albero per esempio fissata lo voi in
quel momento si avvicina si avvicina poi
si trasferisce ecco quell'albero diventa
un qualcosa di particolare dimostrano
avete fissato un momento dove nella
confusione totale avete scelto una cosa
è evidente come cambia il senso della
dico non dico della vita ma il senso del
ragionamento ci abbiamo reso mello unico
quell'albero immensa gli altri lo
abbiamo estrapolato da un contesto
generale abbiamo riso nobile e abbiamo
capito poi che se uno arriva a un
milione due milioni 10 milioni si parte
da uno ecco quella elemento è un
elemento estremamente importante e dopo
con di visione quindi condividere e
condivide significa bussare nella vita
di tante persone quindi degli altri ed
entrare non ci preoccupiamo
se entriamo impossessandosi del corpo e
anche della testa e questo secondo me
l'elemento importante che ha segnato per
esempio l'esperienza anche della mia
vita io so che qui non si può parlare di
sé però ho deciso che parlerò di me e
quindi credo di aver posso dire
approntato risolto il problema
un piccolo passaggio a quello che è e
che voi conoscete nella grande
esperienza di gifuni idea ma pure qui le
intuizioni
immaginate che in tanti anni fa non mi
bastava il solo programma questo
programma che è stato sempre imponente
lo sarà sempre
mancava di qualcosa di pilastri di
pilastri e quali pilastri un team per
esempio ecco quella è stata una
intuizione ultima un'idea che però sta
governando del mondo se tutti hanno
adottato il mood un tema e quest'anno
anticipando quello che è e deve essere
l'impegno nostro nel mondo appunto della
natura dell'ambiente in tempi non
sospetti nella prima volta nella storia
c'è un programma che dura tre anni
un'impresa impossibile per i creativi e
il tema di quest'anno è l'acqua perché
il tema generale è la natura l'ambiente
e la salvaguardia del nostro pianeta
l'anno prossimo quindi l'aria e le 2020
quando si compirà 50 anni avremo
concluso la prima parte e mi auguro
felicemente archiviata una delle più
belle storie italiane ma continua a
trasformarsi l'idea non è il fatto di
essere sempre è così arrabbiati con se
stessi
e così incapaci di modificare
naturalmente sto parlando di patologia
creative perché poi si modifica si fa
appunto uccidendo quando uno è
insoddisfatto reagisce
l'insoddisfazione deve essere deve a
governarci perché appunto ci spinge a
fare tante altre cose bene chiudo anche
con qualche minuto di anticipo
so che il tema generale sono le onde
quante cose potevo dire sulle onde
io ho visto trasmettendo onde c'è un
trasmettitore e c'è un ricettore a volte
ci contendiamo robot succede naba bene
oa volta non sono capace di trasmettere
a voi impossibilitati a ricevere
io credo che noi dobbiamo essere capaci
appunto di reagire alle onde che ci
arrivano in ogni momento in ogni
occasione in ogni luogo
questo concetto del mistero
dell'intuizione io credo che sia un
argomento che si affronterà ho chiesto
perfino all'università di salerno di
mettere dentro alla facoltà di scienze
della comunicazione anche scienze
dell'intuizione e li ho visti
particolarmente felici di questo nuovo
modo di entrare nella vita
dell'intuizione vediamo
e allora che cos'è l'infezione aiuto
l'indizione è un sasso che si scaglia in
testa e provoca un bel nuotate buona
giornata
[Musica]